here for the leech has titled Rena yeah
we're like close to one minute to the
start of the tournament so first of all
I hope everything works out
technically I changed a couple of things
and installed a couple of things I hope
everything works out fine most important
to me would be to learn if I'm
everything is is fine okay that sounds
good
yeah so am I featured on the front page
not yet yeah okay maybe it takes a
moment to catch up I don't know let's go
into the child arena we're starting
pretty shortly twenty-something seconds
I installed some things so there might
be things popping up here like can you
follow us and stuff and I hope this is
not distracting or I don't know it works
out fine no oh my goodness so we're
starting oh okay
I haven't played any games to warm up so
hope it works fine also know what I mean
this is bullet so it is not so easy to
do the commentary in this short time
span okay I've got a good position here
against Baron one two three okay
Ethan coming up I'd want to trade here
my tongue to distract me here okay I
don't mind trading now hey giving me the
night I still setting some problems here
somehow nothing that is unmanageable of
it slightly annoying let's get the king
closed and that that should stop things
check
yeah so I'm winning this one
yeah the connection is I think better I
am okay I'm on the page here this is
good yeah we don't know who is on here
yeah I mean in terms of the world
champion maybe he's on in some funky
account he made a new account for the
for the first for the first time when he
streamed and yeah also it's possible it
seems it should be possible now to
donate to my cause here and there should
be a notification on there but please
don't be unhappy if I'm not seeing this
or respond to this immediately simply
because of the playing time so I see
that there are notifications for four
new first check for followers and it's
good to see that that this work so the
donations probably also work but it's
something that
of course it's not yet tested okay
malice ending that's not too bad I
didn't play that well now I know why
this better not better actually not good
okay I resigned that one
I hope these messages like was following
it's not too irritating the thing is I I
wanted to make them smaller but then you
couldn't cannot read them I think it's a
it's a question of setting this up
correctly and I didn't set it up
correctly but I was spending too much so
much time on that already that I felt
okay let's keep it like that no this is
probably okay for like you can't even go
fo f what is he doing here the end game
would be quite comfortable Wow
it's a chemical we're not a real temple
yeah well played here by Baron
especially nice how he won the horn it
was a nice shot I didn't see that coming
oh this is the nation thank you okay so
that works that's nice yeah doesn't that
doesn't look good
well what a bad position
taeju coming
yeah this is really completely lost yeah
okay not good not good
so Ronaldo seemed did all kinds of crap
opening sea air like the pond Gianni
yeah but okay if if people mark your f6
of course are you making fun of that
really bad opening and then you blunder
the big center pond poor charlie is
really just a bad opening I should have
taken on g2 immediately of course so I
don't want want you to cancel that
easily and this I have covered let's go
here
there is a crap opening even though
cousin played doctor drunken Steen yeah
I had him there was a really suspicious
account yeah a funny name and everything
it could be said Magnus although I'm not
playing the Latvian no not even in
bullets yes how funny is that I should
be what should be fine yeah but I don't
see your way forward well okay well this
is tough a tough tournament
I mean I'm seated to son number 60 so if
I'm in the 50s it's not totally terrible
okay fire glass oh dear I had some like
you I hope the connection is steady
okay it's a nice position from white
like nothing terrible for him but I'm
definitely about to be preferred him I'm
not sure that I played this well
actually pretty sure that I didn't play
it well okay that's not bad for me but
the night comes to d4
it's a good position 86 is weak yeah
that was well played and trading off his
trading office dangerous piece King h8
should have gone de mediately good
defense Wow very well defended you
babbling Wow
poor so I won at least a couple of games
gorilla I don't know who that is
gorilla no maybe at five I don't know I
have some like Ashiya crap Oh what is
that it is some like issue come on
what do you have some more you just
problem I don't know that's always
highly irritating oh thanks for the
donation
jamoke right I don't know if that was a
good move one looks very weakening but
that person has 2,700 yeah I just I my
bamboo ah okay okay
[Laughter]
lots of streamers yeah isn't that great
yeah we have like eight streamers that
you can choose from some playing some
just commentating a gasp
sollozzo as another streamer yeah this
is something that I recently had on the
board actually in a real board game no
I'm drinking tea green tea no white wine
yeah this is winning for black but the
problem is it's extremely wacky and
can easily overlook stuff mmm this one I
don't know this one
I came let's irritate YTM that is
dangerous to say the least
Queen over to a5 is the idea
win this one double-check okay okay so
I'm kind of okay what I'm doing it's not
terrible it's very very tough it's
really tough
we've got 139 not sure Oh Tony chess
that's also regular stream and
commentator so we have a basically a
Slav exchange variation here that's
interesting okay
it should be should be slightly better
it's nothing special probably and now it
is something special I should win this
technically speaking but also this is a
good rope to win okay we've got 164
players competing that's nice cook Mazel
oh that's a long night but I get into
Cairo anyway and people keep playing
those bad lines but to prove heat them
in bullet chess is a different matter
this is also pretty terrible for black
it would be like unplayable in a in a
tournament game almost in connection oh
yeah this is this is so irritating at
this kind of connections per app you get
reconnecting and then everything is
screwed up okay Oh Kings crusher in
there as well
Knight c3 you have the knight on the
left yeah that's the title okay so the
death cannot be bad for the like really
weird keep this back yeah thanks to all
the new followers as well so yeah my
connection is stalling him they've lost
six seconds crap sorry
yeah I don't know you know the reason
for the connection problem I'm losing
all the time yeah he's golden that he
doesn't lose any time
position is excellent for black
[Music]
blundering everything I only hope is
okay I can actually checkmated wait no
pre-move maybe I can it's made in tree
so I managed to get the maiden yeah with
three seconds on the clock
yeah the stream works fine it is a
connection to any chest that is somehow
somehow the issue this it so badly and
now I'm losing like 10 seconds or
something yeah like you know 10 seconds
down and of course I really wonder what
that is if it's just my connection or
what's going on here
I had connection issues the whole summer
some time before now usually the don't
think you should blame the leeches
server it it usually is extremely fast I
mean it it's faster than chests or corn
or anything else just that maybe the
circumstances are not good okay
yeah it could be simply my connection to
that particular server because I had I
had huge issues again in the last two
weeks with the things and it's it's very
much possible that it's something very
specific to to my stream to my
connection okay
against this person here it's some
dragon but okay I have to focus anyway
it's I'm totally irritated by the
connection problem it's very difficult
to to get anywhere against the strong
players like that if you have such a
connection issue attacking his queen and
in return so I'm a queen Oh weird that
wasn't good he's good he's got three
pieces yeah that's a lot
it's probably still good for me because
of the coordination I'm simply winning
the how soon okay yeah yeah it is I use
unity media so I still do I mean I've a
question in the sciences internet
service provider in Germany and they
have I mean they had two issues him what
is age six that's a really bad move
okay it's a really bad one for a play
down age six is completely ridiculous
[Music]
huge problem here that position is
completely completely terrible I
shouldn't play the Bologna in the first
place I have no clue about it they just
take takes too long to figure out now my
default Putin definitely won't be
published this month it will definitely
be February what GM is streaming the
tournament I don't see a GM streaming
but
okay we have a nympho twins gambit type
of structure and I wonder here and she
for coming I was opening this up
shouldn't the G file be dangerous here
for for him ah so jean-luc became a
streaming okay but is probably not he
just only chess I understand
so can I double on the G file here I
think I can
that looks pretty awful cannot move the
F pawn still is good doing a good
defensive job here in this rotten
position
so how would job to actually win this
shape trick no I cannot do that
make sure you still I need to find the
odd good move here come on mate okay at
least the connection was a little bit
better now penguin GIM is also streaming
so Orlando Bloom yeah I don't know who
that is
so yeah let's do this
yeah g5 [ __ ] yeah this is always a
little bit tricky this kind of thing but
shake
[Music]
that takes g3 mate it's the thing the
funky one there was a stupid move
there was a really stupid move
okay so how do I win this crap
it should just win but the winning
position
Queen d5 or something ah I did trick me
wow he tricked me and then from that
completely it was a completely one-sided
game okay I'll take this
mr. Rosen has just given me the big
center pond I see five is a check it's
not nice yeah it's still a pretty good
position it was a kind of our city
Knight is doing absolutely nothing there
[Music]
that ambition key fortune coming okay my
time is bad position I love clothes okay
actually very okay I don't know why I
spend all that time yeah see if to draw
here almost won that ah how long did it
take in me from 2008 oh two two thousand
two hundred oh my god actually two years
maybe three years something like that I
would need to look that out wasn't
something that happened so quickly
my wife is a [ __ ] ah come on let's
that's that's bad
wow that was really terrible
ah okay but I think the connection has
improved this is this is important so
that I can actually play this tournament
to an end I mean it doesn't make any
sense with a completely crap connection
and this this is okay relief
okay yeah who will win the candidates of
course a good question I have no idea
Mahmoud yarrow was really in good shape
at the moment maybe he's got a shot but
you will you will simply not know until
the the very first round is is starting
I know that is probably not correct but
it's not that either we know the
connection is crap again
actually not not so easy for him to play
this Queen g5 is a pretty substantial
threat okay take it
yeah I'm completely winning but I might
lose on Tom
crazy I've got five seconds on the clock
he just wins by doing or whatever yeah
that's not time it's like made next step
- yeah without the connection I would
probably have lots of extra points
that's a bit of a shame I I don't know
what what the reason is quite clearly if
it is ohm just my connection already
just having in the show I don't know you
I heard the other streamers don't have a
particular particular problem and I'm
lagging again they're losing ten seconds
for nothing
that's right turn everything over
knowing I don't know what should I try
off speech I went on I mean you mean my
whole my whole system we are not not
during the stream yeah this time that
time yeah it's maybe some kind of
routing issue I don't know again my
internet has been terrible in the last
couple of weeks
it's very difficult to play like that
it's also absolutely no fun having
because you know you're going to lose
games like that that you that you just
don't lose ever here if you have a
normal connection
[Music]
playful meeting it it didn't only
charges some maid I have lost all time
I'll also dive yeah I give it some some
more tries but it's kind of pointless if
you kind of pointless
yeah no it's better a little bit at
least so yeah this is a somewhat better
end game for white
maybe I mean I'm not sure how bad it is
but okay now I should be okay yeah
nothing gets us from the equal maybe I
can try to invade
assume position it's a winning move it
let's see if I can convert well you just
resigned so I get a win that's funny I'm
not funny it's nice together get him in
yeah
drunken Steen yeah I mean if mangoes
place that she turned evil he will
usually usually win this justice botch
yeah let's see no no I got him yeah this
is fairly nice for white but it's not
easy to play and I forgot the theory no
I'm a pawn up
I'll try to push the night away on the
corner yeah I shouldn't have gone for
the endgame probably rather try to
checkmate yeah he's got got the other
rogue coming
yeah I've fallen a bit behind
I mean that happens if you if you lose
30 seconds per game come to the
connection 97 coming up
what so I get to keep this put 12
seconds but he's got even less time okay
it's better now our internet I don't
know
again I had issues with my provider I am
changing it but that is only in effect
only in effect late February take still
take some time Linda Greene who the heck
so night age for Bishop age 3 as my idea
play against his weaknesses have three
on the cards I should also consider
that's a good move now what is dunya is
not objectively working but it's of
course playable and bullet shares
got too much stuff hanging him nah yeah
super mostly okay yeah that's great you
got it but then your mouth slipping Wow
that's buzzer King against me really
play complete nonsense right play on
three moves and the berserk really
irritated me then that that depth credit
I have to give yeah absolutely I mean I
mean Beezer King is crazy how many pre
moves can you make crazy crazy no I
don't preserve back it's just too crazy
to do
[Music]
okay so destroyer double nines
thing goal in hmm I didn't really want
to do that and my connection is terrible
again just post 8 seconds for nothing
yeah I don't know should I just watch
Magnus play or why should I continue
this I don't know this 38 second
[Music]
yeah once in a while it is okay again
that's a funny thing
yeah it's not main lack I'm okay with a
bit of lack but I mean it just I just
come on 11 seconds snap the 17 moves
[Music]
yeah okay it's kind of pointless
that's not 90 f6i that that kiddie trick
what no I'm not turning off the stream
and just record it doesn't have to do
anything with the streaming I don't
think it has any relation to that I
actually think it's a general internet
issue of my provider
you know he's I'm blundering d6 can I
cannot focus if you know you're going to
lose on time anyway okay no I'm not
continuing this it doesn't make any
sense
so um let's see if I can watch a bit of
rock art it's got 30 second he's 30
points ahead okay so how do I follow him
actually he I am follow okay so let's
see how this how this works how do I
actually watch the games I have to do
that no watches the games so let's see
if I can on if I cannot have I can just
watch
so do we assume that is Magnus is that
that was that confirmed yeah like you
supposed to be Haryana Quran alright so
we have a reversed kind of baloney thing
yeah I mean black locust should be okay
here but white also has his targets so
I'm yeah black has won a pawn but white
is still active and now rook has been
blundered so okay so let's see defending
the universe against doctor drunken
Steen kya karu Knight f6 this is
currently in fashion
Queen Queen III Queen e6 hey it's funny
yeah I think actually this is a slightly
better position for why this is part of
my f1 repertoire actually
but doc ain't got many trades and my how
things should be completely equal but
they reach that in ten seconds and it's
an ending so let's see what what what
Magnus can drum up it's it's like
completely equal there is no one oh
that's a mistake
I'm p8 and now black is a bit better at
least see for the pretty terrible
mistake
I mean it's bullet of course but now
black is clearly calling the shots
no Luke Emma Luke a3 maybe I'm pushing
the King back and now he can advance
it's also a force more is weaker simply
yeah
Brooks is 6 through K 2 wide resigned
yeah that's not a bad decision here down
like six seconds and poo question here
by Peter J taking any new students
anytime soon
no not at the moment I'm currently I'm
happy with the students that I have I
certainly want to forgive the current
students I got a good service and if I
take more it's not going to work out
also want to have some time for projects
like this yeah like doing some streaming
and so on
and that is a really bad position for
for Magnus oh yeah that looks bad it's
not even easy to not getting checkmated
[ __ ] lame he has to keep things close
trade off the bishop maybe and simply
locate the position that is really
really bad for Greg yeah trying for some
counterplay that's night-night to deform
yeah and black is somewhat alive again
he did it good job there I mean now
black is black is fine probably in a
bullet came black is definitely fine ruh
coming on the second-ranked probably
look h2 at some point
oh I just he spots all those tactics so
quickly and black one
yeah completely unstoppable yet actually
I'm not like surprised but I'm still
amazed that with non increment he's also
I'm that dominating with with the 1+1 no
I mean he's not going to lose on time
then and he simply plays better than the
other good bullet players but then you
see see you saw the like him yeah he
just jumped I don't know it doesn't tell
me my ping
that freedom master beaten before that
that big rider from Indonesia okay yeah
so let's have a look at the position is
extremely closed I don't know does it
help if I open a command line in ping
glitches I don't know I rather want to
focus on under my chess games him
there's a suggestion how did I add the
view account yeah that's a plug-in that
I've found here from from I think it's
called stream and apps also Ustream
let's to to to get this donation button
on I think it's great that Colin can
actually play when they will compete
tomorrow in Tata Steel it just shows
that they have fun playing him and I
mean this is really just for fun it's
not like they need the money
yeah some black is winning them stream
laps is it stream laps stream lapsim
yeah somehow Townsend get probably loses
this again yeah it's not it's just like
it's just a thing that happened today
with the bad connection to leech as
usually I have pretty good connections
to each other leeches
yeah and Magnus is indeed losing no etc
I did wrong no cannot be a draw it is a
draw funny
some are saved that one cabling
astonishes now yeah pretty pretty okay
therefore black I think yeah but White's
development is good and she's got got a
space oh very quick a check there on the
FL night 65 now should win or black
resigns simply yeah Knight takes d5 here
this one okay okay let's go pen pen
penguin GM actually one thing I don't
don't like yeah that that he's got to GM
type la because he's not a Grandmaster
simply I mean he's on the list to get
the title but it's not a GM so when that
is also DJ's shouldn't allow that I
think because it's just it's just it's
just not correct I mean he's got all the
norms and and stuff so he will get the
title of course I mean it's not it's not
sure I mean but he's on the list to get
it that's not a pure of technicality
because the few they have those rules
they have to check all the applications
and stuff and I think people should wait
until they actually get the title I mean
yeah yeah thiourea if you will get the
title but normally he would but but it's
um it happened before and incorrect
norms or stuff like that just like you
don't do it before you get it Oh
acha yeah with pre-move countenance
queen down and he continues that's funny
that's funny
Bishop g5 is a good trick move yeah it's
a really good trick move here this one
because you pre move pre move a success
what's something it doesn't want to
resign it seems and now black reside
let's go in Jones he also plays he also
plays a tata steel a group so so yeah
it's a it looks fairly equal this
pollution
I think widest sorry blankets blankets
okay now this is a case where the night
is better night is more move early and
the bishop cannot take anything yeah I
still have Lexia so it's not very it's
not a very fluent stream let's say okay
black is two parts up now and then the
double rook ending and he's got GNH pong
running so how that would that will win
fairly easily unless you stumble into
some some weird mating trickery but it
doesn't look like it no black wonders
yeah again thanks to all of you who now
follow on my twitch my twitch channel
what I also want to want to add is that
I think there are a couple of guys
already in the chat who know that my
Monday Night Live shows that have been
on the ISS see for I think close to
three years that they have been
cancelled but I'm still going to do
Monday shows and I'm going to start this
again simply on leech as next Monday so
it will be next Monday Monday evening
Central European Time that I'll continue
I hope the streams actually working
because it shows I don't get a game yeah
said relay is this everything cool here
now I need to refresh okay so yeah I
mean I post all the streams on YouTube
so I'm not going to do a yeah YouTube
[Music]
YouTube videos in addition to the
streams I think it makes sense to do the
streams and that and then put that put
that on YouTube yeah this is Magnus
playing doctor drunken Steen is
supposedly magnets cards and so let's
stuff yeah Brooke age three let's see
why this also also on the attack but
black is threatening Queen g3 at least
with the draw don't think if like maybe
black can also win a gem Knights you
fire there is no maid now Queen hangs
and a king edge to it like has no good
check and now why does probably check
matching
wouldn't ya that's media 96 that's made
Wow
I will say was cool so yeah black
resigned white is made in yuan b7 he had
toy box also very high rated will not
play him yeah so this is some this
started with the with a Benoni black is
very okay yeah the bishop he has
extremely strong the d6 pawn looks
dangerous but he's now taking it in the
next couple of moves now
the d6 pawn will fall and then the game
should be very much better for black
he's just stopped taking it and now he's
taking it yeah that was irritating I
would have taken that much earlier being
irritated by the pawn who and then
queenís is lost yeah black black should
witness with f4 go for King side attack
Bishop h3 is also coming yeah and who
wouldn't here for Magnus against I walk
yeah I think he's probably winning the
event anyway but it's really impressive
to to watch the game so we got an
English here and with Bishop before this
is a very complex position yeah we will
visit Berlin for the candidates yeah
absolutely
I will be there for four weekend yeah
sure I mean like from them from the
level of play that could also be in a
camera on another top three player out
of five or something but it's um I think
John would be camera confirmed that it
is Magnus yes what what what I read in
the chat 96 it's a nice shot attacking
everything attacking the night hanging
on yeah I mean you have to see those
people are strong
yeah I'm using twitch for the live
streams instead of YouTube live streams
they just have the better clock in
technology you can integrate things much
better and I'm only now exploring things
there there will be more oops I did I
pretty easily got this counter in for
example and you can integrate lots of
things I have to think about this a
little bit and and check out things but
it's much easier to do it
never believed to it said yeah you're
right you're right
so this was again this is Kara with the
double up on black has pretty nice good
yeah good centralized pieces that same
yeah Magnus should prepare for Tata
Steel but but I don't know who is he
playing tomorrow
that's Dmitry Pallas could be German he
actually could be a GM I mean I mean I
think he already got the title but I'm
not sure
yeah Magnus has the better ending here
and probably oh what's going on here 93
that's complicated their tactic coming
no yeah yeah he's black winning yeah
let's do look out there one pawn wasn't
the qiyan Pony and maybe not maybe not
Oh Magnus blundered a piece there a
trick Arriba right
they even winded I mean yeah nice nice
job here but but there was trickery
right there was something really really
funky yeah Bishop a5 dirty trickery okay
yeah yeah ah pervaiz and that's also I
don't know who that is actually but he's
very high rated him
yeah okay this is a funny position here
black played some pretty ancient line in
the Queens gambit declined and he's a
pawn up but it white has very white has
an active position and has won an
exchange okay
that is a very dangerous attack that's
winning actually Bishop g6 and now a
check on the age file yeah and operation
reside mmm probably that was a good
position at the beginning who's on the
eraser this is one of those super strong
Iranian a itself the the problem is
actually they have those I have problems
with the name simply if you lose on yeah
I don't know they're very strong they're
very strong those kids yeah Black is
fine yeah like it's fine
a little fuchsia yeah that's probably a
I cannot even pronounce it yeah strong
real strong kids yeah we got roughly 100
viewers which is cool I'm happy about
that being featured on the front page of
Li Chester's help yeah so let's have a
look at the games here like this active
yeah black it's two pawns up so very
nice job here but black yeah we we have
140 at some point um but my connection
issues probably made some people quit
understand the level you know
this is probably still a drop it's
probably still a draw the black King
position I okay you managed that isn't
that funny
this is the same ending that manga said
against chronic the GG pawn with the
king in front of it
[Laughter]
that's cool really really cool yeah no
it's a dead draw with the two G pawns I
mean it's also a ball but this is this
is just a complete draw yeah you put the
King on g1 and just aive yeah nothing
happens here yeah okay it's a draw
it's funny how quickly I can do that
yeah I came and it's supposed to be
Fabiana right I'm not the king he said
that wasn't funny it was a funny Mouse
lip oh my god yeah it happens to the
best players as well
yeah he's six don't see 7s that's bad
yeah and that's completely completely
lost yep right okay you have to fight
yeah
kickin e7 it's a bit of a shame here
that this match we had this bad Mouse
leper Magnus but would see you know okay
it's it's probably objectively lost but
he's got some kind of activity because
the night only three is such a funky
piece
oh okay there was no where was no fork
but the d1 look was blundered Oh
oh my god this is getting crazy but okay
black is a rock up now right so Carlton
has swindled it Swingle dis really nice
his King is wide open but yeah okay wide
resigned yeah he's got the a39 it's just
so bad okay let's see yeah it's so like
47 minutes so yeah if you like my Monday
night shows they will be on again
starting next Monday and on Twitch I set
up yeah I set up the time so you could
like I'm going to refresh this I think
there was some kind of oh jungle Bahama
that's funny so the two former
schoolmates play and yeah so I'm going
to do the live streams Monday night only
chest and yeah this is all this is an
event on Twitch so I think if you follow
me on Twitch you should get
notifications about that I'm so quite
knew about about all this so I hope I'm
right and this is media through a 727
mate or here probably never win the rock
that's also good enough on Monday night
live shows I probably will just play but
I have not really decided
yeah maybe I will do an announcement
video on my channel probably yes but I'm
not going to do that every single Monday
I mean I kinda feel it's kind of silly
people want to watch they should just
follow me on Twitch so another GM
opponent the warning Viceroy extreme on
YouTube and twitch parallel what is the
point what is the point I don't know why
would I do what what what do two streams
accomplish at the same time while we're
talking about this Meghna seems to get a
beating here yeah I think that would be
weird if he said maybe maybe you can
survive it
I'm not sure about this as a discussion
if Magnus Carlsen actually quit shul a
school before yeah before final exams I
don't know about that I don't know why
it wouldn't surprise me because I mean
why would he actually waste the time to
finish it I mean I think he took took
some time off school when he was like 13
14 or so and after seeing the results I
mean it's really kind of pointless to
waste time of course you go straight
professional them very nice job like
it's a piss-up and he stops the stops
the outside porn yeah and yeah like was
winning that looked really really
awkward yeah at the very beginning so
let's see this revenge time yeah he
Dmitry won against him so I'm like it's
the Kings Indian attack and Magnus went
for I would Vinick set up this is
extremely comfortable for black I think
black is already better here it's easy
to plague our five you can go F for g5
and so on every was a strong a check
yeah and the results I know I'm doing
the signals for the I so see why not I
mean that's not a that's not they didn't
cancel this show I like to do the I like
to do the signals
yeah I think this is a good position for
for white yeah I did stop to play
because my connection was too bad so I
went on to kibbutz um Magnus games you
see here by the way that's a nice
teachers feature that she has won all
the four games yeah now this is a nice
one yeah white is a pawn up but but the
main thing is that the bishop 1.5 is so
strong so white now will build up a
long-term attack a 45 it's extremely
extremely bad for black the rook is
almost trapped down I will nice shot
there nice shot
we should take g6 the King takes this
route you form a queen g4 yeah my yeah
my connection is so high still sucks
yeah it's possible it's possible to play
singles on each other of course and this
is something that I probably will do at
some point we have to see them how
exactly one thing for example is I mean
on Twitch if I get at some point I get
to twitch this twitch subscriptions
possible and I could maybe play against
subscribers for example it's not it's
not a bad thing to do but I would also
do it and you like against against
viewers we have to see so black is got
the bishop here and should be okay here
but there are also some weaknesses in
this position so it's not easy for him
to make progress
now I make it it says I stopped
accepting your challenges I don't know I
tried to play whenever possible you have
to see if I'm only chess
I usually not just hang around because I
usually teach so if you challenge me on
the chest it just happens that I'm
usually just busy and I simply don't
take any challenges at all basically
because I'm doing stuff so um this is a
bad ending and mangas should win this
yeah the night oh he tricked him somehow
what happened here oh my god and now you
will get age five hurry nicer when I'm
winning this end game I think that was a
lost game at the beginning and now he
tricked him
no I tricked him and I mean the h-bond
will promote pretty nice then you know
he bit upper basin four four zero let's
see he has to be careful yeah there's a
funky premisis so we have a timer knob
Sicilian it's probably some like M now
I'm a huge like yeah again I'm kind of
helpless yeah my connection is a problem
it can be all kinds of things general
issue or we have this thought this storm
today in my part in Germany and that can
also be affected
yeah I don't know about the preparation
of course they should prepare for the
games
and in the Tata Steel gentlemen Bishop
d7 I can take and but it's possible that
it's possible that in some cases they I
mean they know beforehand they play with
black against yeah at this person with
whining and this person and they can
they can prepare the forehead wow this
is a draw but in bullet I'm black yeah
black is favored okay should be a draw
the night is always tricky NT I've
landed and blundered to Bishop yeah we
in my part of Germany and the community
the whole train transportation was was
was stopped young what did i do them oh
good game said playing no pesum that's
an ax handle ramirez small american
grandmaster ramirez is a good chess
commentators riot done some good job
here for that for the st. louis people
really like his commentary style it will
be quite insightful not so much engine
ridden let's say uses the engine but not
in a way that annoys me as some other
people do okay so here I am
what's going on White has some attack
but who ninety six is a terribly
terribly powerful threat might be five
also looked strong but this is winning
yeah this is winning
yeah and then there's a like you're
probably black has lost already f it
happened exactly yeah that's it
he resigned in the meantime yeah again I
hope this will improve in the future I
actually always had very good connection
so to reach as it only like since I
returned early early January returned
from a vacation my my internet got worse
worse and worse and today is really
awful
which again that could be due to our
situation with the storm he needs by 58
points it's crazy it's crazy ie wins
Maliki f50 him
complicated but the rook is hanging
first and foremost yeah maybe he can get
to 3,000 it's possible
so where this is opinion on the bishop
that will fall the thing is that the
clinic position is actually probably
better for black yeah
this is this King a safe Lucas you to
check you just pick you know just grab
on see one that's Queen d8 at the end
yeah I knew I should use those those
arrows more but yeah it's not so much in
my system of here on during a live
commentary of course I use that all the
time form for lessons but yeah there are
many top GM's playing Kiwanis playing
what's the question in the chat yeah and
again they're like black one extremely
extremely impressive result
and we have jumper camera again h5h for
like a Magnus yeah I mean burn chest you
can try those things yeah not easy not
easy at all for white to handle the
screen with a Czech human okay but now
probably black has to go back c7 is
hanging which was covered it's a pretty
weird position but yeah yeah both things
things go very quickly here this is not
easy to commentate on a bullet game one
issue for white of the week on light
squares a queen to have three stuff like
that but blacks position looks as we
have the bavarian swiss in the chat and
it looks like Swiss cheese as I tend to
say it really looks quite open blacks
dexplex position here objectively white
should wind us but of course there is
some trickery now if I was hanging due
to the pinion of the Queen rook takes e4
as a move now not sure how good it is
but this is technically possible
mr. pond cannot take probably legging
here
I don't think Magnus is taking a couple
of seconds here I actually did look aged
six Wow he won the Queen oh my god you
won the Queen's how did he do that I'm
to get rid of the tough friggin arrow
who did he win the Queen now what a
trickster
it is quick oh my god
meet yep meet and give me tree again so
the Emmaus lost the first one wonder
second so there is a revenge time again
I'm a grandmaster no no why why should I
mean I'm just I'm just kidding singing
yeah he's extremely fast so here I am
already black resigned the he's
completely lost here the Queen was
trapped Wow Wow yeah when 3,000 is the
goal but it's tough to hear only wins
yeah
very little points if he is if he's
beating people like Dmitry here sorry I
did not want to initiate the computer
analysis okay
I just wanted to refresh the screen to
be honest yeah well it seems it didn't
make a mistake there no blunder at least
in bullet so what we can do is I can we
can briefly check how the position is
leading by more than 60 points more than
60 points ahead of penguin GMR Karpov is
the fight for the other places is pretty
it's pretty stiff yeah but first place
not really a he can you can actually
stop playing now if he wants yeah he's
not it's not necessary for him to
continue he's playing again so let's
watch
so that was probably yeah I'm Agnes
Strider what is called this miss Maurel
gambit but it was declined and now he's
got a very comfortable Muraki C bind why
does a lot better here was chance as to
a check on the kingside yeah that is
very nice okay well defended public
really well defended he is probably
still worse but it's not it's not
terrible well if he gets honk if he gets
a point that is not worse at all
actually very good play verb like to
stay on the sustain the game no it's a
very very good knight on e5 it does not
take all that much yeah counting
displaying this well he's really good at
those things now the king is coming up
to deform godrick a3 coming maybe still
black is playing this well I'm really
good stuff 95 is subject so very very
well yeah excellent job by the black
player
[Music]
I mean position wise this is probably a
draw or maybe why does better about
three seconds that's the problem
I mean causes really quick but know that
he will lose on time very like him one
second okay yeah why he managed to get a
drop position or not sometime what beer
does a german drink yeah actually yeah
besides some Bavarian beer said the
variance whizzes on earth I like Czech
beer
pills that work well is my favorite
brand so we have a yeah Hedgehog here by
Magnus and funny funny move over here
with both sides I think blundering like
will promote ship c5 yeah the issue here
would be White's completely open Kingdom
90g form King is completely open h4 h5
maybe I guess one right
I guessed one right oh what's going on
here
okay black has called an item the it's
extremely dangerous I think in a
practical game I still take black
in Borah chess especially so the night
how do you get the night in there 94 for
92 92 check good job here and white is
defending the Scranton nation's name and
the King is stopping the pond and manga
should win I know he pushed the young
cause yep
the variance with is advertising
Agustina be on yeah I agree I tried this
when I was in the very last last year
that was really good stuff
okay
so Fe Aikido here against you run VDS
yeah why does a little bit better but
it's nothing too special here Queenie ax
3 I would expect no we didn't do that
prevents e5 surprisingly allowed dad
so take group shakes and white is a
little bit quicker on the D file but it
should be wrong that was very dry
yeah you cannot trade now because then
your pawns get weak I guess and I wait
no white gets you outside pawn it just
completely lost
what did black do there I mean okay it's
bullet of course but white is just
winning easily now push a 5 yeah and 1-0
now that was a bit too quickly player
when you have 30 seconds you can still
avoid this kind of thing but anyway
analyzing a bullet game is always a bit
a bit tricky and not to fair simply no
funny and this is a really bad line for
black that Magnus went here went indium
and now it's okay again but okay it's
bullet anyway yes net should be to
snatch a to take everything the black is
two pawns up
you should have six and now if you put
the Queen on to see if our King g7
probably the black queen will try to go
to c5 which is a very good spot cover d6
you know yeah white has some attack yeah
with the H pawn that it's not to be
underestimated this is this is not so
easy
the black is a couple of points up but
Queen takes f6 is very dangerous
yeah that is dangerous
isn't that lost bishop you can move the
bishop somewhere Queen take c7 well good
job he wear white I don't see a defense
yeah this but it shouldn't it shouldn't
hold him I thought Queen d8 and then
okay yeah the white wins the Queen and
ten checkmates yeah good shopper white
really good job / white
so Appa bees again I have a English
opening it's actually pretty good bullet
opening you can put our many many moves
quickly but Carlton forgot to play 95
but you should usually do with it's not
it's not that terrible that's true we
have consonants not paired against Penny
penguin jam or that offer that's true I
don't know I'm not sure about them about
the pairing system how this is how this
works
yeah better for YT this position a for
probably stop the pawns or regroup the
bishop Queen f3 Bishop d3 this kind of
thing yeah thanks to mate in 47 yeah
I'll be back with with more streams
definitely the Monday is stream but it's
possible that I do something before that
depends serve on subway on my schedule
ok you have black rose idea it makes
sense a you down like 22nd and the
position is lost
okay ah ah Harry Joseph time tie isn't
that I don't know anyway this guy beat
manganese two times but now Magnus has
got a good I had a good opening you know
he has a good score it's so fun
yeah black is okay I think here the
bishop on g2 is not doing that much the
only role of the bishop is to color c6
or okay that's nice
where's the Queen going you have to
watch out here for another move not a
move then white is happy about yeah
they're nicely played em no III is weak
Queen to b6 coming
I think Magnus is going to win that rook
takes e3 or this one good
Yahoo takes G 2 and then 9f5
made on G 1 yeah so good revenge game
yep like ours even in the score against
this guy - Harry Joseph seems to be a
really good bullet player ok Carlton
gets paired with number 33 in the
tournament yeah it's a shame that I
couldn't continue would it be cool to
play this one game against him even if
you get your butt kicked if so oh why
does blundering e-4 that's bad yeah it's
a good a good point that in the chat on
leeches that Carlton seems to have a
soft spot for DS in Linux it was Danny
the donkey the first time and now we
have dr. drunken Steen you really or the
other streamers are playing even chefs
network he was supposed to just do the
commentary rook check no one s main on
f7 they should cover the maid rook ma
this is not a happy move but you have to
do it it was like he played this quickly
yeah my connection was was too bad
already had this issue earlier today and
that did not get any better
unfortunately I was quite happy with the
first couple of games I think I played
ok Queen takes G to mate coming
yeah just like 15 minutes
Oh Fareed fear mangia funky name
so okay cousin goes for a ready opening
Queen b3 Bishop b3 is the thing yeah
this is a slightly better position for
why'd you go Bishop before 94-94 yeah
not before and so on before not at the
moment
okay take now I can do it yeah again
quite nicely defended by black like ass
: okay position him 95 is this nice and
attacking c3 and interesting
I'd be six the idea that white has is to
make this Bishop on h7 look stupid yeah
just network was supposed to just do
commentary so would be it would be
surprised if you would have played at
all yeah tough tough year for Magnus
yeah very well played here by black but
now I think he blundered stuff and he's
Dwight is going to be a bit no actually
he takes c3 yeah I mean white is
probably better he will be better after
the rook trade for sure where white is
better
the rooks are stronger and Bishop still
sucks on h7 can play for me movie eight
yeah that's probably going to be made up
like resign yeah very nice hereby by
Magnus
[Music]
you
that well at least I could switch off
switch off the sound so let's see what
Yaron can do him we have this car online
again with a takes f6 the good thing
about this line for black a sec you have
a completely safe King that's a good
thing in input thanks for the donation I
don't even see the don't even see the
amount there because I screw it up
thanks a lot
I have to someone I couldn't figure it
out yeah I have this window area here
for the for the followers and send the
donate and the donations but somehow
it's always like extremely big I
couldn't really figure it our anyway
black is better in the sending it could
be it could be a draw but no it's not a
draw black will get a two and have the
the past a pawn and that should be
winning with the bishops according it
oh yeah the point is promoting fantastic
it just promotes there was there a
picture of Grizzly Adams that's possible
it's really possible if you donate you
can actually choose a picture I think
that's going to be on the rich profile
okay we kind of penguin against GM not
GM penguin yeah I am okay so let's see
what what happens here we've get okay
and funny what car does here g4 h four
against the get the super solid opening
so extremely sharp it is only the second
game in this industry event that those
two play yeah white white should be
better here probably quite a lot better
why went okay Magnus is completely
winning here but you have to you have to
still win it at the end okay Queen d6
Queen f6 check wins and this wins the
the poor the the P step Bishop d5 maybe
the 94 okay that's a very
straightforward win I think this
position and this time I win actually
and black Rosanna absolutely zero chance
no chance at all
yeah I mean it's a difference if you are
I mean it's like 300 points rating
favorite in in real chess and that
translates to bullet at some point
that's very risky but okay again in
bullet chance you can do 85 it's a lot
better for white very risky opening here
by Magnus yeah but it worked out very
well
[Music]
yeah simply black it's okay yeah
probably yeah counter checking very nice
and winning the pawn
why not somebody take it okay
he returned to these six I couldn't
figure out why taking was bad Queenie
one day I saw that one it's nice it
takes takes night f1 that's a nice nice
shot
yeah like takes takes night f1 yeah that
is not so difficult to spot but still
nice so nice
okay do I still have some tea in this
frame I have I wish that actually mainly
a mansion I played a play to her before
good bullet player
then white white has clearly better
position here of course black black
needs to get some counterplay Thomas
Benson okay well I played Thomas Batson
in in the second second league okay
seven groups okay seven was winning his
father played really bad game and he had
a winning position but it was not so
easy to figure out yeah white white is a
lot better than I damn rookie is winning
the Queen and black resigns yeah we know
we know the deal rock is some fourth
place we said actually said Knight each
or something atomic world champion who
is that our car fifty I have no idea
atomic was the topic world champion okay
so yeah white has a really great
position here with the two bishops and
Bishop c6 but now the two bishops are
attacked how does he see aa shot so
quickly that's really amazing
over completely over the rock is
strapped I cannot simply save it one
Knight takes bishop takes also wins
Italia Wow how many points to see hat
let's go to the two that quickly 65
points 65 so let's go and let's call us
again he's really doing a great shopping
we won two times against Magnus so
that's going to be interesting he's just
don't know 15th place here and so he put
up a real fight I have to draw here yes
can you avoid to draw yeah no now okay
that's a bit anti-climatic but yeah
Magnus had to force the draw here
Queenie for a mean white is a piece of
also
yeah quickly explain what makes him so
much better than everyone else
quickly probably not but I know in those
quick time controls and he's really
extremely quickly spotting spotting
every single tactic somehow is
technically very alert but he also has a
fantastic fearful piece placement so
quite often the games are not so
technically sharp they just have fun
this kind of this kind of harmonious
setup ok wins the piece of b1 yeah nice
um just just by putting up everything
harmoniously yeah very nice oh that's
not going to end well I can tell you
that I don't think playing such a crap
opening is a good idea against Magnus
with with no development Queen d8 made
route 65 coming maybe pawn takes and
then some a six stop okay here this is
the thing you have to keep the
initiative yeah
Queen d7 now is the threat look at the
ad takes f7 really to mate that's a not
difficult to spot but it's a nice mate
no you can take on the eight I think and
maybe take take Bishop a5 check you
might not be made that d5 okay what is
that stretch Bishop f7 maybe now it's
it's not afraid to trade Queen say okay
it's so I've got an ending
with an exchange of and dominating
pieces yeah and ten seconds on the clock
what I really feel is quite amazing that
the caramel manages a very quick pace
also in games where he is not actually
doing all that well like he has a bad
position sometimes but he plays so
quickly that it doesn't really doesn't
really matter all that much
okay that's technically easy when I line
up on the same should win quickly yeah
and black resigned no chance at all so
the tournament is actually over and he
finished with the performance and two
thousand nine hundred ninety four with
pain pension I am or GM whatever second
place sixty point difference opera is in
a third place with 120 points yeah
extremely extremely impressive
performance there by a by Magnus I think
we agree that that that is him really
really nice and yeah this is this is
$1,000 for for the first the first place
[Music]
anybody let's say says something in the
Chet 1332 players in the shed at school
they're really really busy the server
yeah so at the end I did play some some
games at the very beginning but the
connection ended the tournament
me and fortunately but we got to watch
some really nice games by what is very
likely the world champion and is
extremely strong as we have seen in this
time control so I hope you enjoyed that
about my streams again I will definitely
stream next Monday that's a given is
already in the twitch.tv schedule you
can see the time its 11th 11:00 in the
evening on Monday it's one hour later
then I usually started a salad at 10:00
for the SEC but I will start at 11:00
now because my lessons before have
delayed a little bit so 11 is the time
to start yeah thanks a lot for watching
I hope you enjoyed it it's been very
enjoyable for me and once I could focus
on the commentary and did not have to be
angry about my connection issues okay
thanks a lot for watching thanks a lot
for all the new followers of the channel
and also thanks for the donations okay
bye bye guys I'll be back soon